a former national security adviser in
the Obama administration denies any
wrongdoing when she asked for the names
of trump associates picked up by united
states surveillance some Republicans say
Susan Rice should be questioned under
oath the Senate Intelligence Committee
Chairman says rice maybe one of interest
in its probe of Russian election
meddling major Garrett is at the White
House major good morning good morning
former National Security Advisor Susan
Rice has emerged as the central figure
in president Trump's long-running claims
that President Obama either ordered or
tolerated some form of surveillance of
mr. Trump and his associate and the
motives were more about politics than
national security the allegation is that
somehow Obama administration officials
utilized intelligence for political
purposes that's absolutely false Susan
Rice denied she did anything wrong when
as national security advisor last year
she asked for the identities of trump
associates caught up in electronic
surveillance of foreigners completely
false rice also categorically denied an
unsubstantiated report that she ordered
the creation of spreadsheets with the
unmasked identities of Trump transition
figures and distributed them among the
intelligence community i leaked nothing
to nobody and never having never would
Kentucky Republican Rand Paul said rice
should face very specific questions she
needs to be brought in and question
asker whether President Obama ordered
this or whether he knew about it the top
Republican on the Senate Intelligence
Committee said no decision had been made
on whether rice will be asked to testify
if there's intelligence that leads to
her she'll be part of milia are reviewed
former CIA and NSA director Michael
Hayden said it appeared rice acted
legally the process that has described
is perfectly normal and on its face does
not in any way constitute a smoking gun
questions about Rice's actions and
motivations have for the moment
overshadowed the three ongoing
investigations into Russian interference
in the 2016 election Texas Democrat
Joaquin Castro told CNN Tuesday evidence
may lead to prison sentences for some in
mr. Trump's orbit I wouldn't be
surprised effort all of this is said and
done that some people end up in jail
CBS can confirm that Carter Paige a
former foreign policy advisor to mr.
Trump's presidential campaign was
approached by Russian spies in 2013 long
before pages involvement with mr.
Trump's run for the White House page
Nora is now part of the FBI
investigation all right major thank you